Happy birthday DNews, Trace here!
I think my favorite episode of DNews might
be the time I got to go to the North Pole,
that's pretty awesome.
And go inside the seed vault.
And then go to The Large Hadron Collider all
in one trip.
That was crazy!
2016 phew what a year!
Happy birthday Dnews!
I may not be your host anymore but that doesn't
mean I can't still learn from you.
Episodes like Should You Drink a Bottle Of
Wine A Day?, Is Smoking Weed While Pregnant
Dangerous?, and The Four Weirdest Animal Penises
remind me why I subscribe to you in the first
place.
So happy 4th birthday and here's to 4 more
years of hard hitting scientific investigative
journalism.
I miss you guys.
Happy birthday, DNews!
My favorite thing about being on this show
is when we bring up a topic, some people have
never even thought about and they get really
excited to learn about it.
That's the best part.
That and when people react to all the jokes
I put in my videos.
You know what happens when you hold your pee?
Urine trouble!
Who is writing these?!
Okay that's the best part.
And then educating people is, is like, is
a close number two.
Happy birthday DNews!
Thanks for being born.
I hope you're having a wonderful day and I
think my favorite episode was... did Anthony
Carboni drink breast milk once on camera?
And I'm not totally sure why.
But I'm sure there was a very scientifically
valid reason for it.
Thanks DNews!
Happy birthday DNews!
Congrats on 4 years.
Probably one of my favorite times hosting
on DNews was doing that sex space gecko episode
with Trace.
So congrats on four years, here's to at least
another 4!
Happy birthday DNews from New York City where
it's raining and I can't thinking about Trace's
episode on acid rain.
Kinda forgot about acid rain but now I want
to know how much sulfuric acid's landing on
my head!
Hey guys, Jules here, wishing DNews a very
happy 4th birthday.
It's a huge milestone.
So my favorite thing about working on this
show, by far, is you guys, the commenters,
who are so quick to pick up on all the little
jokes, all the little, even the little mistakes.
My beard, my mustache; lot of comments about
those.
And I love them.
Keep them coming.
Keep being you and we'll keep being us and
making fun, informative videos.
Oh hi there, DNews, it's Natalia.
I wanna wish you happy fourth anniversary!
And what's my favorite time or moment at Discovery?
Well, that would have to be, an episode I
did about race.
I was also able to talk about the work of
a good friend and biological anthropologist,
Dr. Robert Sussman, who has unfortunately
passed away this year.
So I'm honored to have been able to cover
such a controversial subject but also featuring
the work of a prominent scholar, friend and
anthropologist, Dr. Bob Sussman, so thank
you.
Hey guys, it's Amy and by far my favorite
moment of my time with DNews.
two and a half years now, is when Trace and
I blew up that pie for Thanksgiving.
Because A. I was not expecting the flame to
get that big and B. I'm the smart one.
I ran from the fire and Trace is the dumb
one who stayed and watched it and then he
had to pull me back into the shot.
That was the first, my first DNews field trip
and that was so much fun!
Happy 4th birthday DNews!
I'm so proud to have been on this show for
three of those four years and I hope we have
many happy years together.
Happy birthday DNews!
It's been an amazing 4 years of science communication
and I've been privileged to be doing videos
with you now for the last 3 years and if I
remember back to my first video.
That was with Trace and we were talking about
gravitational waves.
I wasn't very good and that's when I realized
we got some really, really good editors on
the team.
So thank you DNews, thank you to all the team,
to all the producers and all the hosts for
making my time with DNews a fun time.
I'm looking forward to the next four years
of awesome science videos.
Take care.